in this video I want to show some
examples of graphing quadratic functions
but before I do that I want to make one
fairly minor correction to the end of
the last video where we did some
factoring with grouping when I showed
you the proof of why that works I
multiplied F X plus G times HX plus J
and when I multiply them when I did the
first term I said FX times HX when I did
it in the last year I just wrote F H X
and we know that that's not true we have
F times H times X times X it's fh x
squared that times that is fh x squared
and then the rest of it I had gotten
right it's FX times J so plus we get F J
X and then we had G times HX so we could
write that as plus G H X and then
finally G times J which gives us G J so
I apologize for that error I had
forgotten to write the exponent there
and I think I had forgotten to write it
in the step after that but it didn't
change the argument for the proof I at
least didn't mess up there so I just
want to make that quick correction in
case that confused anyone and I also
made a small annotation in that video if
you're watching it on YouTube with that
out of the way let's learn to graph some
of these quadratic functions so let's
say I have the function y is equal to x
squared minus 2x minus 8 and what we're
going to do is we're going to rewrite
this quadratic expression on the right
hand side we're gonna write it in
intercept form and that essentially
means just writing it in its factored
form then doing that we're able to
figure out the x-intercepts where we're
intersecting the x axis and then using
that we'll be able to figure out the
vertex and I'll show you what the vertex
is in a second so let's just factor this
this quadratic on the right hand side so
we get Y is equal to so what are two
numbers where their product is negative
8 so they're gonna have different signs
and then their difference is negative 2
well let's see if we have negative 4
negative 4 and plus 2 when you take the
product you get negative 8 when you
add them you get negative two so we
could rewrite why is being equal to X
minus four times X plus two so this is
essentially writing this quadratic
function in intercept form and now let's
figure out where this intersects the
x-axis so let me label my axes this is
of course the x axis that is the y axis
so when will something intersect the x
axis the x axis is when y is equal to
zero right so let's set this equal to
zero zero is equal to X minus 4 times X
plus 2 we've seen this multiple times
before this means that either X minus 4
or X plus 2 or both of them have to be
equal to 0 so X minus 4 is equal to 0 or
X plus 2 is equal to 0 so that means X
could be equal to 4 we're just adding 4
to both sides of that equation or
subtracting 2 from both sides of this
equation X could be equal to negative 2
so these points where we intersect when
X is 4 this term is 0 so the whole thing
is 0 Y is 0 that's how we solved for
this so the points 4 comma 0
and the point negative 2 comma 0 are
going to both be on this parabola so
let's graph them so 4 comma 0 let me do
this in a darker color 1 2 3 4 that's 4
comma 0 and then the other point is
negative 2 comma 0 1 2 negative 2 comma
0 is right there so that's the two
points where we intersect the x axis and
now we're going to determine something
called the vertex of our parabola and
the vertex you can kind of view it as
the you just just to give you a sneak
preview parabolas are the graphs of
quadratic functions and so the graph is
going to look either like an upward U or
a downward u it's gonna be shifted
around on this but the vertex is either
this minimum point or this maximum point
and the word parabola just describes
this function shape it's the shape of
the graph of a quadratic let me write
that
these are parabolas parabolas so to
figure out the vertex you actually just
take the x-value that's halfway in
between the two intercepts no matter
what the intercepts are going to be
equidistant from the vertex are going to
be equidistant from the vertex so that
is the graph those would be our
intercepts and then our vertex is going
to be an x-value exactly halfway between
them so to figure out the x-value of our
vertex we just average these two x
values of our x-intercepts so let's do
that so we could say the X for the
vertex we could call it that well let's
call that well yes it's called that X
for the vertex so that's why I wrote a V
there is going to be equal to the
average of these so four plus negative
two over two which is equal to this 4
minus 2 which is 2 over 2 is equal to 1
so X is going to be equal to 1 and what
is y when X is equal to 1 so Y the Y for
the vertex is going to be equal to 1
squared 1 squared I'll just write that
as 1 minus 2 times 1 so minus 2 minus 8
so what is this this is 1 minus 10 which
is equal to negative 9 so the vertex is
going to be at the point 1 comma
negative 9 so we go 1 and then we go
down 9 so X is 1 and then Y is negative
9 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 so it's right there
and so if we were to graph this parabola
the line of symmetry is on the x value
of the vertex so let me do it in the
darker color than that so the graph
should be symmetric around X is equal to
1 and the graph will look something like
this I'll try my best to draw it BAM
it'll intersect the x-axis there and
it'll be symmetric and look just like
that on the other side and it'll go BAM
just like that I think you get the
general idea and then the other point
that you may or may not be interested is
the actual y-intercept if X is equal to
0 you mean
see that y is equal to negative 8 so the
point 0 negative 8 should also be on
this graph and let's see if I drew it
right 0 negative 8 right there should
also be on that graph let's do another
one of these let's do another one
and let me I'm kind of taking up some of
the space for the next problem so let me
clear this let's do another one all
right so let's say we have let's say we
have y is equal to 2x squared plus 6x
plus 6x plus 4 so here the thing that
immediately strut jumps out at me is
that I can factor a 2 out of everything
so I could rewrite this as Y is equal to
2 times x squared plus 3x plus 2 that
saves me the pain of having to do the
factoring by grouping that we talked
about in the last video and this we can
factor in a pretty straightforward way
this is C 2 times 1 is 2 2 plus 1 is 3
so this is X plus 2 times X plus 1 right
2 plus 1 is 3 2 times 1 is 2 so that's
what Y is equal to so if we wanted to
know the the x-intercepts we figure out
where this expression is equal to 0 so
we said 0 is equal to 2 times X plus 2
times X plus 1 remember we want to
figure out where we intercept the x-axis
that's the x-axis there Y is 0 on the
x-axis so sorry my phone was ringing so
let's get back to this problem so either
of these 1/2 can be equal to 0 obviously
the two can be equal to 0 so we get the
situation where X minus X plus 2 is
equal to 0 or X plus 1 is equal to 0 I
didn't have to write the parentheses
there subtract 2 from both sides of this
equation we get X is equal to negative 2
subtract 1 from both sides of this
equation or X could be equal to negative
1 so the points negative 2 comma 0 you
put negative 2 here this obviously
going to make y is equal to zero and and
the point negative one comma zero same
argument those are our x-intercepts let
me graph it we have negative 2 comma 0
negative 2 comma 0 is right there
actually let me do this graph a little
bit a little bit bigger let's say that
this it right here is let me label it in
double step so let's say this is
negative 1 let's say this is negative 2
that is negative 3 1 2 and this is our 3
that's our 3 that's our 1 2 3 just like
that negative 1 negative 2 negative 3 so
I'm using two blocks to represent one so
the point negative 2 comma zero is on
our graph or it's our x intercept so
negative 2 comma 0 is right there and we
have negative 1 comma 0 which is right
there and then we want to figure out the
vertex well the vertex is going to be
the average of those two so the X for
the vertex is going to be negative 2
plus negative 1 over 2 that's negative 3
over 2 which is the same thing as
negative 1.5 now what is y equal to when
X is negative one point 5 is going to be
a little bit involved I'll use actual 3
halves so we get Y is equal to Y is
equal to 2 times negative 3 halves
squared plus 6 times negative 3 halves
plus 4 and let us figure this out so
this is equal to 2 times 9 over 4 minus
you have that negative sign there and
then we could make this 6 divided by 2
is just the same thing as 3 over 1 so
this is minus 9 3 times 3 plus 4 this 2
over 4 is the same thing as 1 over 2 so
this becomes 9 halves minus 9 plus 4 so
let's simplify this minus 9 plus 4 is
the same thing as minus 5 right minus 9
plus 4 minus 5 we can rewrite is equal
to minus 10 over 2
9-10 all of that over 2 is minus 1/2 so
our vertex our vertex of this parabola
is the point is the point minus 1 point
5 or negative 1 point 5 negative 1/2
this is our vertex so we can graph it
right here negative 1 point 5 negative
1/2 our vertex is right over there and
then we can graph this parabola and if
we want to do the y-intercept we can the
y-intercept is going to be here when x
is 0 Y is equal to 4 these terms cancel
out x is 0 Y is 1 2 3 4 right over there
and then we can graph this parabola it
will look like that that's my best
that's my best it should be symmetric
around the x coordinate of the vertex
just like that let's do one more of
these let's do one more of these and
once again I've used all my real estate
up let me clear this out of the way
let's do one more
let's say that I have y is equal to
negative x squared plus 10x minus 21
once again let's write this in intercept
form we just factor the right-hand side
we get Y is equal to well the first
thing I want to do is factor this
negative 1 out negative 1 times x
squared minus 10x plus 21
now what two numbers when I multiply
them they're positive 21 so they have to
be the same side and when I add them I
get negative 10 at least in my brain
negative 7 and negative 3 jump out I
mean there's not that many factors of 21
so 7 and 3 are probably 2 that
immediately jump out because they add to
10 so you have Y is equal to negative 1
times X minus 3 times X minus 7 negative
3 plus negative 7 is negative 10
negative 3 times negative 7 is positive
21 so if you want to find the
x-intercepts the x-intercepts are going
to be where so we could set this whole
equation equal to 0 negative 1 times X
minus 3 times X minus 7 our x-intercepts
or the X values that make y equal to 0
are either the ones that make X minus 3
equal to 0
or the X values that make X minus seven
equal to zero add three to both sides of
this equation you get X is equal to
three add three to both add 7 to both
sides of equation you get X is equal to
seven so we get our two x-intercepts the
point 3 0 1 2 3 0 and the point 7 0 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 0 now we know that our vertex
is going to be right in between them so
the X for the vertex is going to be 3
plus 7 over 2 which is equal to 10 over
2 which is equal to 5 and the Y value
let's figure it out
y for our vertex is going to be negative
negative 5 squared so negative 25 plus
10 times 5 plus 50 minus 21 minus 21 so
what is this this is equal to we have a
negative 25 a negative 21 you add those
together you get a negative 46 add that
to 50 you get Y is equal to 4 so the
vertex is at five comma four five comma
four let me graph that the vertex is 5
comma 4 so 1 2 3 4 5 right in between
and then up 4 1 2 3 4 so notice
something in this graph over here the
last two graphs actually I think I just
cleared them you saw that the you saw
that the vertex was below the x-axis so
when we plotted the x-intercepts and
then the vertex the upward forming
u-shape was the only option but here the
only option is a downward u shape in
order to this being a either the minimum
maximum point and going through both of
these points and having a u-shape ru is
going to have to look something like
this now you let me draw that a little
bit better the U is the U is going to
have to look something like that that's
a better better shot at it now notice
what was the difference between this
equation and the previous ones the
difference was is that this one
had a negative in front of the x squared
the coefficient in front of the x
squared was a negative number and that's
why we have kind of a downward-opening
parabola if this was a positive number
we would have an upward an
upward-opening parabola so that's why
this one is kind of a downward shape and
it's vertex represents a maximum point
it's the highest point on the parabola
in the previous videos we had an upward
opening or in the previous problems we
had an upward opening parabola and our
vertex was the minimum point